Now to growing concerns
about the deadly coronavirus
officially hitting the U.S.
One person with coronavirus
in King County, Washington State has died.
So it's been two years
since the first case
of Covid was detected in the U.S.
And we've had a major scientific
breakthrough since then,
vaccines, antivirals, probably
what's most significant
in the background is genomic sequencing.
That's the work that's been
done by scientific labs
to figure out what mutations
people have of coronavirus
and what those mutations do
when they do infect a person.
It's really to help adapt
vaccines really quickly
and prevent that strain
from doing a significant
amount of damage.
I headed out to Seattle
where they had detected
the first case of Covid in the community
to ask the scientists
who've been on the frontline
of Covid detection and
mutation surveillance,
are we any better prepared?
Yeah, sorry, this question
makes me really mad.
I'm hoping we've learned a lot of lessons.
So we're in downtown Seattle.
When I started thinking
through the question
of how do we assess whether or
not we're any better prepared
for the next pandemic?
All my reporting actually led here.
And basically the reason
Seattle was so prepared
by the time coronavirus came
along is they had already
started a project called
the Seattle Flu Study.
It started in 2018 and
by 2019 they were doing
this swab and send program where people
could take a nasal swab,
which you probably had
never thought of doing
before the coronavirus pandemic,
but people were doing it
here just to figure out
what kind of respiratory illnesses
were circulating in the community.
Because they were in this position
and they were doing this work,
they found the first case
of community-acquired Covid
in the U.S.
We're here to talk to the
scientists who came up
with that project and who
are hopefully gonna see that
through and perhaps expand it.
So the Seattle Flu Study started in 2018.
And at the time we called
this the Seattle Flu Study,
mainly because when everybody
is sick in the winter,
they think they have the
flu, even if they don't.
And secondly, as a prototype
pandemic preparedness platform,
everybody thought the next
pandemic would be a flu
or an influenza.
So these are samples
from the Seattle coronavirus
assessment network.
We're interested in what's
going on in the community
with people who are infected
with some respiratory pathogen,
they're not sick enough
to go to the doctor.
What do they have and can we find it?
So when somebody signs up
for the Seattle Flu Study,
usually it's because they've woken up
with some sort of illness and the person
follows the instructions
to swab themselves
and put that swab safely in
a tube in a specimen bag.
We test it for Covid and 20
something other pathogens.
We found out about coronavirus
just like everybody else,
through the news.
We immediately saw that,
hey, if we just turn on
a test for coronavirus at the same time,
we can be screening
for all of these things
to understand what coronavirus looks like
in the community right now.
There was already a
massive outbreak in Europe.
There was kind of no way
that it wasn't here already.
We just weren't looking.
So it was really not surprising at all.
And we found one within the
first 400 samples we ran.
The results of the sequencing
that labs like Lea's get,
go into bigger systems that then feed
into a program called Nextstrain
that was created by Trevor Bedford.
So tell us what we're looking at here.
Oh boy.
So here we can see the
viruses that were collected
over the course of the pandemic.
Trevor's work focuses
on where mutations are
and how they spread around the world.
And it's work that he's
done for other diseases,
particularly flu.
And that's part of the work that gets done
to like help build the new flu shots
and also work that's been
adapted to tuberculosis,
Ebola, even Zika.
So it's the kind of genomic
and scientific sequencing data
taken to the next level and
shown in that real world,
here's where the threats are,
here's where the virus
is emerging kind of way.
So there's many countries,
many geographies that
didn't have any sequencing,
and now they're up sequencing thousands
of viruses every month.
And this is a huge step into the future.
How this whole thing works,
how this genomic surveillance works
is that right now people will
get tested for coronarirus.
Each of those swabs will result
in a 30,000 letter genome.
And so each of the samples will have
slightly different mutations
in those 30,000 letters.
And you use that to look for
variants that are emerging
and how they're spreading
and kind of learn a lot
about both the evolution and
epidemiology of the virus.
So this is viruses that
are currently circulating,
that were collected from
the very early pandemic.
So this is going to be
Wuhan in January, 2020.
The first sequencing was really helpful
to establish human-to-human spread.
So this was at a time
when China was downplaying
human-to-human spread,
but Chinese scientists
were openly sharing their sequencing data.
And after that point, the
sequencing was really helpful
to understand how it was
spreading around the world.
And then subsequent,
it's been really helpful
to understand variants and their spread
and whether one virus
is more transmissible
than another virus.
Basically, if we can get
the whole world to be having
the ability to detect and sequence Covid,
it would give us a headstart in terms
of when the next pandemic is emerging
as it could emerge from anywhere.
My intentions are,
and to the extent that I could
have any influence on it,
there will be a broad,
comprehensive approach
to pandemic preparedness
and response at every level.
I mean, there have been calls recently
for increased pandemic preparedness
and building more capacity.
One might imagine in
a future where there's
a lot of great respiratory
disease surveillance,
people having a swab in their home.
And when they got that cough
they would swab themselves
and then send that back to the lab
and they could test
for multiple pathogens,
that would make a big difference.
My goal is to try to make this
stuff a heck of a lot cheaper
so that we can kind of perform
this sort of surveillance
without breaking the bank
like we've been doing
for the last couple of years.
I'm just worried that before
we can build something
like that on a national scale,
the political world will evaporate
and the appropriations
will evaporate with it.
It's the work that's going on
when there's not a pandemic
that really prepares us for pandemics.
And that probably sounds fairly obvious,
but it's really important
to stop and realize
that we don't always fund that research.
For us to be really prepared
and building better vaccines
that protect us against
threats that exist,
we really need to be
paying for basic research
to be going on all the time.
Without this kind of funding,
so much amazing scientific
work could sit on shelf.
That's really unfortunate.
Scientists in South Africa
are warning of a new strain of Covid-19.
The variant, which is yet to be named
appears to have a high
number of mutations.
In the weeks after going to
Seattle, omicron emerged.
And it's remarkable when
you think about the speed
at which the information about
omicron was made available.
Had we not been sequencing
and had we not discovered omicron,
we would have just experienced a surge
in Covid cases with no reason.
And we would have had no
understanding about that.
And the reason some of this is possible
is because of private money
actually in public health.
Hi Rick.
There you are.
Welcome to us.
Rick Bright is a doctor
who's worked in government
and several different positions.
He was a whistleblower under
the Trump administration.
He came out publicly to air his concerns
about how the Trump administration
was handling pandemic preparedness.
Our economy is spiraling downward,
and our population is
being paralyzed by fear
stemming from a lack of
a coordinated response
and a dearth of accurate,
clear communication
about the path forward.
But he since rejoined
the Biden Covid transition team,
and now is part of the
Rockefeller Foundation
and he's heading up their
pandemic preparedness institute.
I think governments move slowly.
They want to check and double check,
they want to evaluate things
and they wanna be absolutely certain
before they pull those triggers.
And I saw that with the MERS outbreak,
with the H1N1 influenza
outbreak, with the Zika outbreak,
we've seen this repeatedly.
We need to have entities in place
and organizations in place in our country
that can be less risk averse,
that can be more nimble and flexible
so the world can know what's happening,
and scientists and the public can be able
to better respond to those
newly emerging variants.
Do we have enough sequencing
and is it rapid enough for us to be able
to enact public health measures,
to really stem the tide of another wave
of serious infections?
Genomic surveillance alone can't do much,
but genomic surveillance
and sequencing data
is a powerful dataset that we
can use to target resources
to areas where we know there
will be a surge in virus
to bolster the hospital
systems to make sure
there are sufficient medical
supplies in those areas
where we might see that virus emerging.
Genomic surveillance is a
powerful leading indicator
that will allow us to target
our medical countermeasures
and our healthcare response.
The Biden administration
announced $1.7 billion
for improved sequencing, data sharing.
Is it enough money?
Do we need more money to really
build the kind of systems
that we would say really
have put the safeguards
in place that we need?
It was a lot of money.
I don't think the money
has been distributed fully,
I don't think it has been
distributed fast enough.
And we will be fighting this pandemic
in the rear view mirror
until we get in front
of a solid, robust surveillance system
that will also target vaccine breakthrough
and reinfection cases.
Our vaccines are amazing,
they're wonderful and
they're doing a wonderful job
until they don't.
And it's in those few
cases when they don't
where we really need to harness
that genomic surveillance
capability to ask why
We've made a lot of progress.
Don't discount that at all.
My biggest concern though, Cynthia,
is all of these things that we've learned,
even the things that we've
done to make improvements
could just as easily be forgotten
the day after this pandemic ends.
We need to make sure that
we're taking every step
to dig in and implement these new things
that we're learning for a new normal
going forward beyond the pandemic.
Are we more prepared, yes and no.
I think we know what we need to do,
and that's half the battle at least.
We know that we need to
be stockpiling supplies
to build tests.
We know that testing is really important.
We know that surveillance
is really important,
but I am not sure that we're
going to be able to do that
in a nimble fashion, but
I think science is ready.
There are reasons to be
optimistic when you think
about pandemic preparedness now,
as compared to two years ago.
I think we do have a lot
more sequencing capability
in the U.S. and in the
world than we did previously
and a lot more of the
scientific work is getting done.
But probably what's
critically missing here
is the sustainability of funding.
And I think the other thing
that we really need to consider
and make sure that is
constantly in this conversation
is the benefits of sequencing
are tailoring the vaccine
to make sure that it's more effective.
So we need sequencing going
on all over the world,
but we need the benefits
of that sequencing
to also flow through to the
people who are providing
that scientific information.
That those countries are
also getting the vaccine
and making sure that it really
benefits the whole world,
not just a small sliver.